hello hello my name is Adam Smith from
nobelprize.org which is the website of
the Nobel Prize in Stockholm and many
many congratulations on the order thank
you very much your your work using phage
display to engineer antibodies that
became medicines is really a perfect
example of her translational research
would work when you say I
yes because I suppose I started I wasn't
actually thinking about doing
translational work at the time I started
the work so it was much more a sort
interest in how one might create new
molecules in general so I I didn't
actually in my earlier work with protein
engineering I'd just been more
interested in understanding how enzymes
and things work and then I started
moving to antibodies again to try to
understand how antibodies worked and
then I realized the power of very
evolutionary technologist to create
large repertoires of them and to select
them and of course I think there are two
components to the work that were really
very important the first was the
generation of repertoires and making
sure those repertoires were as efficient
if fully folded proteins and then
secondly the way of displaying them on
the use of the phage which George Smith
had provided pointers to so so and of
course having so if it wasn't as if I
thought the very beginning right I need
to create pharmaceutical antibodies you
kind of start working along a different
route and then you find yourself
gradually being you know seizing
opportunities as they come up and those
opportunities were well opportunities to
actually overcome a really difficult
problem which was how to make human
antibodies against human self antigens
and so realized that we could create
this by by using evolutionary technology
some sense is a bit Hallett bit like how
the immune system works you could also
regard it as the
I mean you could think in terms of early
evolution but if you think about the way
in which the immune system works that is
an evolutionary system so we effectively
what we did is we started to rationalize
this in terms of how how can we mimic
the immune system which is a new
evolutionary system to make to make
human antibodies but without all the
checks and controls the immune system
would have that prevent you from making
and yourself antibodies quite so how can
you mimic and then direct correct yes
um yes or what is very important in all
of that isn't there's no that one
doesn't really know where the
opportunities are going to arise so you
have to do lots and lots of basic
research in order to be in a position I
certainly agree with that I mean it's so
- so my strategy my personal strategy
has been to do the basic research Alette
and but to be mindful of opportunities
that may arise in other words not to say
oh well that's applied I'm not going to
do it my own view has been yeah actually
if I just did the basic research and I
came up with a very interesting method
and I didn't take it any further then
people would say well it's just a
curious you know it's a very clever
little system he's got there but you
know it's a bit of a curiosity really so
I thought actually one needs to prove it
you need to drive it all the way through
and so I certainly enjoyed let me just
linking showing off I've just had the
University people here trying to
coordinate all the incoming calls it's
like a seed we can't actually get any
all the phone lines I can imagine you're
a scientist you're an inventor you know
you're an administrator
well it's rapidly fading I can't tell
you
Irene I again I suppose and I don't
necessarily do all of them terribly well
I've done each of them well at different
stages in my life because in the end you
have to say why does the public give
he's willing for a large sums I mean
millions per year to go into supporting
science it doesn't agree to put the same
amount into zoom into humanities and the
reason for that is that the public
believes some good will come of it and
if we want to maintain credibility with
the you know public in general and we
have to show that from time to time
um yes indeed exciting things will
happen and particularly things that are
are in need for the public good so I
think it's terribly important
that scientists don't ignore the
opportunities that may come from their
work that doesn't mean to say some
people say well applied research that
has no place in academia and I I'm not
sure I agree with that but yeah there is
a bit of an obsession now that you put
the focus on application and it'll be
right projects for application and I'm
not saying that's a bad thing
but I think that sometimes if you want
to make big leaps it's sometimes more
effective to be a little bit more D
focused so that you actually focus on on
some basic research and you give the
people the freedom to and perhaps they
expect them to be responsible and if
they don't want to take up the
opportunity themselves at least alert
other people to them so that these the
opportunities latent within whatever
their inventions are are and can
actually be exploited so I think we kind
of have a duty as scientists to do that
but my my personal view I must just very
briefly touch on the LMB it's yet
another Nobel Prize from that
environment much has been said but what
is it that makes it so particularly
special people refer to the lnb culture
as their things one of the things that
makes it special it's an attention to
people are willing to tackle very big
problems I mean problems that are so big
that you you couldn't just solve it in a
grant the kind of problem that you could
devote your your life to I was very
fortunate in having mentors fred sanger
and says our Milstein who exercised the
kind of very benign
mentorship but encouraged us to think
big well I I should leave you to your
amazing day that's about that's
unfolding right thank you so much thank
you very much thank you